If you look at this, on August 23 they
called my wife that they had
kidnapped me and that I had to go leave
some money in a shopping center that
I was not at home at the
time when I got home to
The workers told me what
was going on, what had happened, not
immediately. I went
to look for the commercial decision.
When studying, we found it
later. We had them looking in
several places when they called me 4 hours
later saying that they
had  to my wife and my
kidnapped children then this, yes, that's where
the torment began and waiting for the
calls
we explored the calls and they kept
calling me that they expected me to wait for me a
week later they call me giving the
instructions
that I had to go and leave the money at a
place called Gualco de Guerrero beach
they realized that the police were already
with me and we were no longer able to
contact them and they did not call me until
September 27 where  and we already
gave them the money in which they match
in a place
and it is the date on which they did not receive that
money but they have not appeared anymore they have not
called me until now we do not know
anything about that from my children